In 2017, fans of creepy clown hijinks rushed
to the theater, breaking box office records
in a rush to see the remake of It, adapted
from the Stephen King book of the same name.
The film was met with wide acclaim and hailed
as a new classic... but just because something
is awesome doesn't mean it can't be kind of
stupid, too.
Despite its iconic scenes, killer writing,
and knockout performances, It has its share
of moments that left us scratching our heads.
Georgie who?
If you know anyone who lost a sibling growing
up, you're probably very aware that it's a
devastating blow that can tear apart both
families and communities... except in Derry.
In Derry, you mostly shrug it off and make
fun of your friend's mom.
When Georgie goes missing, the only people
who seem torn up about it are Bill and his
dad.
Probably his mom, too.
Her entire contribution seems to be providing
incidental piano music for her youngest to
get eaten by a clown to.
Everyone deals with tragedy in their own way,
but none of the kids seem to do much to process
the fact that a little boy straight up disappeared
into the great unknown.
Detective Ben
That Benjamin is a heck of a dude.
He's got an eye for detail and an inquisitive
mind.
Would you believe he was the first person
in all of Derry's history to notice there's
an inexplicable disaster every 27 years?
How is it that, in a town that's been around
for, presumably, about 260 years, the first
person to notice this trend is a bored kid
on summer break?
None of the cops or teachers or historians
in this town has ever been thumbing through
A History of Derry and noticed that kids get
killed here on an alarmingly regular basis.
Congratulations, kid.
You're this universe's Batman.
Librarian hubris
We find Ben in the library, studying up on
possible past It encounters.
He's learning.
That's good.
We want him in the library.
There's only one person who doesn't want him
in the library, and that's the librarian.
"Isn't it summer vacation?
I'd think you'd be ready to take a break from
the books"
She kicks a quietly studious child out of
the library.
You know.
Like librarians do.
Was there really a point in history when librarians
were so secure in the idea that libraries
would be around forever that they'd shoo inquisitive
patrons out the door?
If she's still working today, she probably
looks back longingly on the days when you
could evict someone from the library for something
besides trying to live in the bathroom.
History class
Take a look at Ben's bedroom: it's got pictures
and newspaper clippings lining the walls.
And, well, this.
How he got all of this information home when
he apparently can't leave the library without
getting mugged is a mystery in itself, but
that isn't the point.
Who shows up in an illustration?
You'd better believe it's Pennywise, in a
print of the signing of Derry's town charter.
But It showing up in an old image means one
of two things: Either It is doing his usual
routine of projecting into places he shouldn't
be, or else It was there at Town Hall in the
late 1700s and not only did nobody mention
or object to it, but he just barely warranted
making it into the 18th-century equivalent
of the group photo.
How could you forget that face?
Who taught you murder?
As far as we know, It has one job: eatin'
kids.
That's It's whole deal.
It's been popping up every 27 years to do
just that.
So why is he so bad at it?
How many kids does he kill?
Two?
Maybe four, depending on how you count?
The children of Derry would've been in more
danger if a bad flu had hit the town.
And what about the bullies that It eliminated?
In a way, It saved more lives than he took
by nipping those pieces of work in the bud.
Pick a lane, Pennywise.
There's the argument that It feeds on children's
fear.
Two counterpoints: First, in a much more literal
sense, he feeds on children.
Secondly, in the book, It refers to causing
fear as more of a way of "salting the meat,"
which means this dude is risking his life
to season his steak.
Pretty fancy for a guy who spends his time
in the sewers.
Speaking of...
Diseases of Derry
Let's discuss for a moment what makes sewers
so important.
They convey human waste, rainwater runoff,
and our ill-fated goldfish from cities to
treatment plants and disposal outlets.
They're more or less the key thing that separates
us from apes, but they're rife with disease.
And these kids are traipsing through them
like they're a McDonald's PlayPlace.
Sorry, every one of these kids is getting
hepatitis.
Eddie brings this up when they first start
exploring the Barrens, but you know what sassiness
doesn't protect you from?
Cholera.
Maybe we're projecting
The Losers Club heads to Bill's garage, where
Bill has set up what's doomed to be the second
worst TED talk about clowns of all time.
They're flipping through slides when the slide
projector takes on a life of its own, until
a series of photos of Bill and Georgie's mom
undergoes a nightmarish transformation: Mom
straight up turns into Pennywise!
And then nobody unplugs the projector.
"Turn it off.
Turn it off!"
Mike kicks the projector off the table, but
still, nobody turns it off!
Everybody in the room just screams and wigs
out, failing to take their lives, or in fact
the power cord, into their own hands.
Ben's got guts
Tough guy Ben walks off an astonishing number
of gut injuries in this movie.
First, the bullies try to carve their name
into him with a switchblade, which he escapes
by tumbling down a dirt hill and trouncing
through sewer runoff, only to have his wounds
treated by children with drug store bandages.
Then, in the creepy house, Ben gets slashed
in the belly by It, which he just sort of
seems to ignore afterward.
After that first haunted mansion encounter,
he's just standing out in the street with
four foot-long gashes in his abdomen.
You could maybe see his appendix if you squint.
It's worth pointing out that during that whole
scene, Eddie's mom is standing in front of
Ben watching him bleed from his torso, and
she thinks it's more important to shame a
12-year-old than it is to find him a doctor.
The adults in this town are a mess.
Defying death
In a lot of ways, It isn't supposed to make
sense.
It's a piece of horror fiction that deals
in the supernatural.
But still, there's one thing that really,
truly doesn't make any sense.
Specifically, how are those insanely self-destructive
bullies still alive?
All we see them do in this movie is take needless
risks for two hours.
They drive blindly down alleyways at breakneck
speed.
They make flamethrowers out of cans of hairspray.
They dive headfirst down steep hills covered
in debris.
They play with loaded guns.
They're the definition of awful.
It shouldn't have taken an extradimensional
demon to beat these jerks.
With their behavior, every one of them should've
been a full-color "In Loving Memory" page
in the yearbook by their sophomore year.